hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is natalie and i'm very happy to
be here and to be your host for this
session please if you feel comfortable
in doing so please rename yourself to
the name you would like to be called by
in this session would be lovely if you
could also add your pronouns in here and
if by any chance i pronounce your name
incorrectly please correct me at any
time please also know that we are
recording this session i would like now
to welcome anders berkman carl drew and
sophia herbert to our session and they
will talk about computations as athletes
and your approach to reproduct
reproducibility
and transparency dr berkman has been
working with data science and data
processing architectures for the last 10
years he is a master researcher at
ericsson research and a frequent teacher
in machine learning and data science at
ericsson
carl is a senior
software developer with a wide
experience including high-level python
programming as well as design of
efficient low-level libraries and see
our assembler
he is a researcher at erickson research
sophia is a data science with years of
experi is a data scientist with years of
experience and she's part of combine ap
ab group and with that i give the floor
to the speakers thank you for joining us
today
thank you
so hello my name is angus bachmann and i
represent the talk computations as
assets a new approach to reproducibility
and transparency by sofia herbert
caldwell and myself
this talk is based on the open source
project xx
xx is a python library for parallel
processing and streaming of large
datasets
xx stores computations on disk so that
it is easy to retrieve them when needed
things are computed only once
computations are reused instead of
recomputed
the xx project was initiated almost 10
years ago at swedish ai startup expert
maker
it has been used in projects with
customers such as safeway vodaphone and
ebay to name a few
it has been used for data sci data
analysis and data engineering tasks but
also as backend in recommender systems
producing live recommendations for us
customers
in 2016 expertmaker was acquired by ebay
to help advancing their structured data
initiative
and in 2018 xx was open sourced by ebay
under the name the accelerator
since then more than 1
300 peer-reviewed commits have been
added to the project
if we summarize the design goals in two
bullets it is first to minimize risk for
manual mistakes
this is achieved by letting the computer
do boot keeping of inputs outputs
results and so on
and as we will see this leads to an
automated transparent and reproducible
workflow that can be taken directly into
production
and second to maximize efficiency
critical parts are written in the c
programming language results are reused
and not recomputed where possible
processing is making use of all cores in
the machine
and with a small footprint it can be
installed on raspberry pi's laptops as
well as rack servers
let's start with an example
the backplace data set
backplace is a company in the data
backup business they have more than one
hundred and thousand drives spinning
currently in their data centers
every day they collect a set of more
than 100 parameters from each drive and
this data is then shared openly on their
web page
in total the complete database contains
almost a quarter of a million drives of
135 different models collected daily
since 2013.
a number of data science and machine
learning projects have been based on
parts of this data
in our example we have generated a video
visualizing all 250 million rows in this
data set
the video that we will show is rendered
in full hd resolution and runs at the
frame rate of 60 hertz
all source code for this animation is
available on our github page and we will
present a link at the end of this talk
a frame is composed of approximately 2
million pixels and there are 250 000
drives so if we let each drive be
represented by four pixels we can
actually squeeze in a visualization with
all drives on screen simultaneously
then we render one frame for every day
in the data center
in this first frame we see a number of
light gray rectangles that each
represent a number of drives of a
particular model for example this
rectangle here corresponds to a number
of hitachi drives
there are 60 drives per row
because this is the number of drives
that fits into a backplaced drive pod so
this rectangle corresponds to maybe 60
by 80 or 500 drives
over time sound drives will be removed
and some will fail
we have marked the removed drives with
black and failed drives are represented
by an animated circle
i'll start the animation now
the flashing bright areas represent new
drive being added to the data center
somewhere around 2015 backplate starts
adding 1200 drives at the time and we
can see it happen here
and also here
on my screen this animation runs very
smooth running at 60 frames per second
i guess the experience in the other end
of the zoom channel is not that smooth
but the video will be available
afterwards on youtube
note that we are visually exaggerating
the failures approximately one percent
of the drives fail every year and
backplates have a very strong redundant
storage method that has been proven to
work extremely well
now let's go back and see how this was
actually done we start with the very
basics
imagine that we want to execute a
program input to the execution is source
code and parameters such as location of
input data
an output could be some kind of graph
table animation just something printed
to standard out
this image illustrates this very simple
situation with the actual program
execution consuming time and energy in
the center
now what we do is that for every program
we execute
we create a new empty directory in which
we collect and store all input and all
output associated with execution
in addition we also store meta
information about the execution itself
such as for example which python
interpreter that was used and the
program's execution time
so to be specific we store source code
input parameters as well as all output
files and printouts together in a new
dedicated directory
in this presentation we've drawn these
direct directories that we call job
directories in the shape of a chest
now that we have stored everything we
realize that we can query all existing
job directories to see if we program
that we want to execute have already
been executed before
if it has been executed before we can
immediately return a link to the
existing job directory
there is no need to execute anything
on the other hand if we are seeing
something that we have not seen before
we need to execute it and when we do we
create a new job directory and store
everything related to the execution
inside it then we return a link to this
new job directory
as we will show you next this idea leads
to a number of advantages such as being
able to do faster design iteration
but the advantage we will talk about
first comes from the perhaps a bit
surprising observation that we do not
need to name or book keep intermediate
files anymore
the way it works is by using what is
called build scripts and you can see an
example here that builds three jobs
the key idea is that you can use
existing jobs as input to a new job
thereby creating dependencies between
jobs
for example job number two here
the pre-processing job
uses job number one as its input
the job directory associated with job
one contains the data needed by job two
the result of the complete execution is
linked to the jobs creating them using
soft links making it transparent from
which job the results were computed
on a low level here is what it might
look like imagine we have two programs
that we run in a sequence one before the
other and that the first is passing data
to the second using an intermediate file
to the left we see what we might call
the traditional way of doing this we
execute one program after the other the
first program writes for example a
pickle file and the second program reads
the same pickle file back
for this to work we need to make sure
that the file name is the same for both
programs
to the right we see the xx approach
it uses a build script in python and as
you can see there is less code and no
explicit file name
the first job just returns the
intermediate data upon completion
and the second program reads this data
from the source job that was assigned
using an input parameter
internally a file is created by the
return statement but its name is of no
relevance to us
during development
every time we make changes and
re-execute the build script new jobs
that corresponds to these changes will
be built and stored on disk unless they
already exist
this opens up for faster and easier
experimentation and trying out what if
cases
we can always go back to previous state
by just undoing changes in our text
editor and re-running the bill script
which will make all outputs up-to-date
immediately
another thing we can do for example is
to work on two or more git branches
simultaneously
every time we switch we switch branch
and run the build script all updates
will be updated all outputs will be
updated accordingly
and this is the key idea
using xx we will not fetch the wrong
files or consider results that are not
up to date this minimizes risk of manual
errors
and the main reason for this is because
intermediate files are fetched not by
name but by function
if we want a particular file we call the
function that generates it instead of
using an arbitrary file name also
running a bill script ensures that
output will correspond to the source
code and the input data no need to rerun
everything from scratch just to make
sure
let's spend a few minutes talking about
what we mean when we say transparency
and reproducibility we start with
transparency
this image illustrates that the result
in this case a graph may depend on many
source files and many input files
looking at this result this graph how do
we know which files and versions that
was actually used to create it
we want to be able to observe all data
and all source code associated with any
result in order to answer questions like
did we include the last update of the
input data or was this generated without
the patch that we did yesterday and so
on
using xx it is straightforward to view
the source code of any build job
follow the dependencies back to other
jobs all the way back to the input data
and we can do this on the command line
or using a web browser and in the web
view we can also view tabular data
images video files etc it's very
convenient
reproducibility then
reproducibility relates to a number of
things such as fixed seeds for random
number generators and stable sorting
in this context it means that we should
be able to reproduce a result given a
complex scenario involving multiple
versions of source code and data
assume that we have tried different
versions of the code but we already will
always use the same intermediate file
names
this is only reproducible if we know
which version that was run lost
using xx all versions will be available
and the result will correspond to the
current or active version
and here is another scenario
let's assume that we always create new
files question is then which of these
outputs corresponds to which versions of
all these source files
again using xx all versions are
available and running the build script
will ensure that the output corresponds
to the current states
let's now move back to the backplace
example a program of this size is
typically not implemented using a single
program
instead we rely on divide and conquer
and separate the project into a set of
programs that each solve one part of the
total problem
the main tasks in this data to video
product are
importing and typing all the csv files
do the required amending to get the data
set in perfect shape
render all the video frames and then
encode all these frames into a single
video file
this project has two main phases where
the first is to import type and demand
the data the preparation phase
and the second phase is the creative
part where we use the importer data to
create the frames in the video file
this image illustrates most intermediate
files in the projects
input data enter at the top left moves
right and then down and then right again
until we reach the output video file
in between we can see the different jobs
and how many files they create
internally for example the frame
rendering job needs one plus one plus
seven input files to draw all the frames
these files in turn are generated from
the imported and typed data this is
stored as hundreds of thousands of files
out from the rendering job we have more
than 2800 files one for each frame in
the movie which are then video encoded
by ffmpeg into one output file
now why why do we see hundreds of
thousands of files in the csv import
jobs we will get back to that but
basically it is because we have 3 000
csv input files times 150 columns and we
want to be able to read the columns
independently for speed reasons
and in practice these numbers are
multiplied by n where n is the number of
cpus in the machine to take full
advantage of the parallel processing
hardware in a modern computer
nevertheless
these files are never visible to the
user we mentioned them here for
reference but we really don't need to
know this in order to write the program
this table shows the execution times for
the different parts of the project it
also shows how many iterations we did to
complete the movie
importing takes most of the time more
than half an hour and it creates
approximately 3 000 jobs and this is run
only once
amending the data set takes a few
iterations to get right but it takes
only six seconds per iteration
then we need to collect the data to
render and we do this using three
different jobs that executes in 44
seconds and it took 19 attempts to get
that one right
most of the development effort is then
spent in re in the rendering code here
we need to try out what looks good and
what does not
by looking in our work directory we
could see that we ran this job more than
100 times
and in order to watch the video we also
need to encode the frames into a video
file
encoding all frames takes 17 seconds
since ffmpeg can only use a few cpus
so we added a parameter that by default
only generates two seconds of video then
we're down to one second
so the total iteration time from
changing the source code to having a new
video to watch is only seven seconds
as we all know
fast iteration is fundamental for the
creative process being able to try out
ideas in only a few seconds is a game
changer
you may argue that this is fast because
we are using a fast computer
so we also run this on a laptop from
2018.
import them took 45 minutes and the
design iteration was less than 50
seconds
so this is still okay and if we just
render say the first 120 frames per
iteration until we get it right we are
down to maybe 10 seconds per iteration
so what i'm saying is that even an old
laptop can handle a 250 million row data
set with ease
now we move to another example
this time we use the new york city
yellow cab data sets where all taxi
trips in new york
are stored since 2019
this data set has 1.6 billion rows
and to show that it's easy to work with
data sets of this size on a single
computer we've created an animation
based on this data too
this data set is a relatively high
quality but there are a lot of outliers
and a few other issues for example if we
create a heat map of the drop-off
locations for one of the vendors we get
the plot to the top right here we can
see that it looks rather noisy there are
drop-offs all over the place including
the hudson river
and even more worrying is that if we
swap the longitude and the latitude
coordinates a mirror of new york city
will manifest itself somewhere close to
antarctica so some cleanup is required
the data set contains a lot of
information here we have created a
minute by minute representation of the
number of active taxi trips
we can for example zoom in on the
january 2016 united states blizzard and
study what happened then in great detail
the video
the example video that we will show
however
uh it shows the impact of the corona
pandemic to the new york city taxi
business and i will start the video now
you can see two identical maps of new
york city to the left we have 2019 and
to the right we have 2020
and the amount of taxi drop-offs are
visualized in green
now as the number of confirmed cases of
covet 19 in new york city here in blue
increases
we can see that the number of taxi trips
in orange starts to decrease
this video is running at 60 frames per
second where each frame represents one
hour new york time
and this video is also available on
youtube and you can also find the source
code that generates it on our github
page
importing the 1.6 billion rows took less
than 11 minutes
we don't need all this data for the
video but since importing is so fast
there is little point in importing less
then we need to download some map tiles
from openstreetmap
data about covet cases etc and this
takes seven seconds
most of this time is actually spent
waiting in the openstreetmap api
the design iteration then is 12 seconds
for this project and added 26 seconds to
that to encode the full video file
before uploading it to youtube
in addition to what has been already
mentioned xxx has more features that are
required or really helpful when running
projects in production in this talk
we've only got time to talk about one of
them the high performance access data
xx stores tableau data using something
called a dataset is an efficient
representation designed for high-speed
parallel streaming access
the dataset is an extension of the job
we mentioned
data sets could be linked to each other
vertically or horizontally to add more
rows and columns in constant time
and data sets are strictly typed but
there are many types to choose from
including python pixel meaning that we
can include almost anything in a data
set
here is an illustration of how the data
is stored
imagine the taxi data set with columns
such as latitude longitude and timestamp
each column is stored as separate files
so that we do not need to go through all
of the data in order to read just a
single column
i would say reading one or a few columns
is by far the most common case
furthermore each column is split into
separate files or slices so that the
different cpu cores in the machine can
read one file each in parallel
ericsson is an example illustrating how
efficient the data set operations are
imagine that we want to amend the model
column in the back place data set
what we do then is that we read the
model column one slice per cpu in
parallel we do the required modification
on one all the cpu cores and then we
write back the new column one file per
cpu or slice this is a perfectly
parallel operation
and it requires very little memory since
data is streamed through the program
and below here we can see an example
what the code might look like we read
the model data from an iterator and we
just write the modified data to a data
set writer and this for loop is then run
in parallel on all cpus
and the modification we did was
replacing a double space by a single
space in this case
note however that we never modify data
instead we create new columns keeping
the original ones for reference and
reproducibility
now parallel processing works best if
data can be partitioned into independent
sets
look at this example of a data set with
three slices our task is to compute how
many fruits there are of each kind
since for example apple exists in all
three slices
we need to spend time and memory
computing it counting it in every slice
so we can only compute a partial result
in each slice and then we need to merge
all these partial results to get our
outputs
this is more or less how mapreduce works
it's both slow and memory intensive and
it can be done in a better way
the exact solution is to re-partition
the data based on a hash function
we move each fruit to the slice we get
from applying a hash function to the
fruits in this example for we have
apples and bananas hashing to the same
slice and they are marked with red so
all apples and bananas go to slice zero
kiwis and pears go to slice one and so
on and so forth
now each fruits will then only exist in
one slice and we can count them
independently processing is perfectly
parallel and there is no need to merge
anything anymore
in addition hash partitioning is a very
fast operation and is run only once the
amortized cost approaches zero as you
reuse the result
and again data is never modified the
hash partition data is stored in a new
data set so it's just another view of
the same data yeah so conclusion is that
we can have faster development time
fewer mistakes full transparency and we
can work with data sets billions of rows
in a few minutes on a single machine
and here i provide references to the
blog manual and all the source code that
was mentioned in in this report thank
you
thank you so much um so we have a few
questions so from alex is this a desk
alternative if so how does it
compare in design and performance
oh that's a very good question
this runs on a single machine so you
don't need to bother to set up a cluster
in order to run it and you can run it on
a laptop or you can run it on a rack
server with with a hundred cpus if you
like
so i would would say it's it's kind of
different
okay we have another question from uh
maxim how fast would your program run if
it used pandas for importing dataset and
pi arrow.parkhead
uh it's it's pretty different we we use
a different way a very efficient
low-level way of storing things and park
yet use another one so they're not
really compatible of course you can
transform from one to the other if you
would like to
uh but we don't have any lock in so you
can actually get the data out again into
csv file if you like
so i would say you don't need to use
formats like pocket to use this you can
just use csv files
okay great so um our time is over um if
you have any more discussion that you
would want to have with the speakers
please move it to slack or gather town
thank you so much to our speakers dr
brickman and carl for your talk and
being part of the pi data global 2021.
thank you